concentré et prêt pour un débat qui doit
nous permettre
Alain à l'autre de
d'expliquer nos idées nos projets pour
la France je regardais votre programme
vos 22 mesures il n'y a même pas le mot
chômage dedans ce qui frappant et pas de
problème alors je veux c'est une
reconnaissance du travail bien fait pour
les 5 années qui viennent de s'écouler
je vous en remercie président de la
République
aborde ce débat sereinement et avec
beaucoup d'intérêt parce que c'est un
moment démocratique important
qui le paye monsieur Macron le bouclier
ce sont les contribuables mais comme la
baisse de la TVA doit surtout parler de
ce son bilan
et d'incarner la fonction et de montrer
ou démontrer aux Français quelle sera la
France demain gouvernée par Marine Le
Pen dans la vraie vie quand vous allez
demander à un frère votre banque on est
tous dans la vraie vie madame dans la
vraie vie quand vous allez chercher
après auprès de votre banque et vous
demande votre salaire et il se moque des
primes il ne m'attends pas du tout à ce
qu'il y ait ou je ce soir un écart
spectaculaire et je pense que au
contraire elle sera capable de reprendre
la main et et probablement d'être mieux
préparé que la fois dernière peut-être
moins fatigué aussi qu'elle ne l'était
en fin de campagne je voudrais pas que
celles et ceux qui nous écoutent pensent
qu'avec vous leur salaire va augmenter
de 10% automatique pardon mais je crois
ce que je peux revenir au blocage des
prix Madame Le Pen est-ce que je suis
content d'apprendre que vous le
maintenez mais vous avez voté contre
quand il est passé à l'Assemblée
pourquoi on se prépare de manière
particulière quand on affronte le même
adversaire 5 ans après c'est pas le même
adversaire
puisqu'il a été 5 ans au pouvoir ce qui
était pas le cas la dernière fois
mais c'est normal parce que je pense que
vous n'avez pas de réponse et non mais
parce que vous n'y avez pas répondu
Madame Le Pen d'abord je vous dire que
ce que vous avez dit est factuellement
faux peut-être l'erreur qu'on a faite en
2017 c'est peut-être de trop vouloir
montrer aux Français la brutalité du
projet d'Emmanuel Macron ce soir je vous
rassure elle va beaucoup parler d'elle
de ce qu'a propose pour les Français de
la vision qu'elle a pour le pays vous
dépendez du pouvoir russe et que vous
dépendez de Monsieur Poutine parce que
quelques mois après avoir dit cela
Madame Le Pen vous avez contracté un
prêt en 2015 auprès d'une banque russe
la First check Russian Bank proche du
pouvoir je demande aux Français de
m'élire Premier ministre
je leur demande pour mes lire Premier
ministre délire une majorité de députés
insoumis
insoumis et union populaire ça n'est pas
hasard si il y a 5 ans la Russie était
intervenue dans la campagne ce qui a été
prouvé pour me déstabilisé et si vous
avez toujours été ambigu sur le sujet
parce que vous n'êtes pas dans une
situation de puissance et puissance que
vous ne pouvez pas défendre correctement
sur ce sujet des intérêts de la France
donc ces deux choix de société qui
s'imposent à nous Monsieur Mélenchon
nous dit qu'il ne choisit pas entre les
deux mais qu'il veut devenir le premier
ministre de l'un des deux c'est un peu
incohérent aucune banque française
n'a voulu m'accorder de près et vous
trouviez ça à l'époque tellement
scandaleux que vous avez fait voter une
loi sur la banque de la démocratie vous
n'avez jamais mis en oeuvre pourquoi
d'ailleurs monsieur Macron ne l'avait ou
pas fait pourquoi n'est pas n'êtes-vous
pas allé au bout de cette banque de la
démocratie plus de 5 millions de kéniens
ont fui leur pays en guerre c'est un
nouveau décompte publié par le Haut
Commissariat au réfugiés de l'ONU c'est
la plus importante crise de réfugiés en
Europe depuis la Deuxième Guerre
mondiale je ne peux pas vous laisser
dire qu'on rembourse pas nous
remboursons tous les mois
rubicerons sous le contrôle de la
Commission nationale des je ne peux pas
vous laisser toujours pas remboursé ce
prêt et pour renforcer son armée de
l'air l'Ukraine a reçu pour la première
fois des avions de chasse mais on ignore
encore le nombre ainsi que les noms des
pays fournisseurs de ces appareils c'est
assez long monsieur Macron oui c'est
vrai nous sommes un parti pauvre mais
c'est pas des honorant mais je n'ai
jamais considéré que c'était déshonorant